[Music]
in the final weeks of the trump
administration the rush to complete the
border wall
is no more challenging than on a
mountainous corner where
arizona and new mexico meet mexico and
the sierra madres here the president's
signature infrastructure project is
particularly challenging to build
and even more controversial because of
the pristine
lands the wall is cutting through
the last 35 miles of building the
president's wall in arizona
is underway in the rugged sierra madre's
mountains
it's terrain so difficult roads have to
be carved into mountainsides
so men machines and materials can sink
the 30 foot high steel beams in concrete
construction costs here have been
reported at 41 million dollars a mile
more than any other stretch of the
738-mile
project but jose manuel perez sees a
greater cost
it's a huge richness of biodiversity of
culture
and relationship between the two nations
we are losing that with this wall
the wall intended to stop people also
stops migrating animals
the biggest corridor for big mammals
like the mountain
lions the jaguars they don't recognize
any boundaries
they've been here forever perez runs a
land preservation organization
cuenca los ojos his border cameras
capture images of the animals here
a local land owner valaire clark started
it all
she learned barren land can flourish by
piling up rocks to retain scarce water
and her crew made tens of thousands of
them
later she bought 130 000 acres on the
mexico side
for cuenco los ojos to care for but i
fell in love with dirt
she also convinced reluctant ranchers to
join the conservation effort
but now decades of work is literally
being blown up
unlike other projects that require
review under the national environmental
policy and endangered species act
some of these protections blew up too
after the 9 11 attacks
the wall is a national security project
and what is going on here has attracted
lawsuits
and spectators the majority of my day
has spent looking through a 400
millimeter lens to find out where the
crews are
john kurtz a north carolina wedding
photographer
arrived after the pandemic brought his
business to a standstill
he's since made wall construction from
texas to california
his focus i think it's insulting people
and drugs
this won't stop any of that what it will
stop and
what's kind of sickening to me is
wildlife migration
you have species that they won't be able
to get through these
migratory paths that will end but
migration
is not going to stop and neither is the
drug trade
president-elect biden wants to stop the
building
and leave motion sensors here already to
track human movement
but until then construction continues
conquering a landscape transforming it
perhaps forever and we reached out to
multiple federal agencies to comment on
the wall's environmental impact but they
have not responded to our questions
certainly